so rather just finished we have four
speakers with us as you can see Austrian
Chancellor Sebastian cools high
representative vice-president federica
mogherini foreign minister of republic
of korea kim kang-hyun wa and foreign
minister of the philippines third or
alloxan who will all say a few words and
then hopefully we will be able to take
some questions
Chancellor cut sir you have the protein
thanks you get dominant ham thank you
very much
dear ladies and gentlemen as it's quite
late I shall keep it very succinctly
thank our Asian partners for having been
so kind as to come and join us here in
Brussels I believe that this whole
exchange between Asia and Europe
is absolutely vital particularly at a
time when multilateralism is being
questioned so I think this is a good
signal profession to Mottola tourism at
many different levels which have
expressed here and there are three
particular domains I would like to
stress here in this context first of all
combating climate change Asia will soon
be the region of the world the biggest
need needs in terms of energy it's
important therefore that we all pull
together in combating climate change and
that we stick to the arrangements and
agreements secondly free trade we need
fair equitable rules based free trade so
that all those involved can benefit in
economic terms and I'm happy that were
able to exchange views on that as well
thirdly another focal point is
digitalization which is changing our
world and the way we are moving forward
the way we work and deal the way we
learn we've got to grasp the
opportunities therefore but at the same
time there are challenges for the
political level for example the needs in
terms of new forms of Taxation but also
combating cyber based crime here once
again we want to strive for
cooperation so many thanks once again to
all of you who came here to bustles I'd
also like to thank the Commission of
course I'd like to thank president truce
and of course federica mogherini for
having organized this event and brought
against bringing us together here today
thank you thank you well I joined my
voice to the Chancellor's one in
thanking our Asian partners in
particular the two ministers that are
with us but also the other delegations
in total European and Asian delegations
of 53 which gives you the magnitude of
these two days with over 40 delegations
represented either at level of heads of
state and government or ministerial
level I think it is the azzam summit the
summit between Asia and Europe and the
highest political level in for sure in
recent years and this tells you the
importance we both attach to this
partnership and definitely out of these
two days of work we come with reinforced
global partnership between Europe and
Asia what we agree together matters not
only to the two of us but also to the
entire world you know the numbers Europe
and Asia together are 55 percent of
global trade 60 percent of global
population 65 percent of global economy
75% of global tourism and if we continue
in the list you realize that together
represent a real global power and this
summit has allowed us to translate this
global weight that we share into
concrete policy initiatives that can
make a real difference for the world the
transfer is already mentioned three key
areas for intense cooperation on climate
change action on free and fair trade and
on digital I would like to mention a
couple of more points that were at the
centre of our work for sure our common
work on security and the issues that are
on top of our foreign policy agendas
strengthening cooperation between us on
international and regional security if
we see developments in our regions both
in Asia and in Europe we see the need to
protect and promote rules-based
international order not only on trade
but also in security and a cooperative
approach to foreign policy in particular
we discussed our full support and our
willingness to accompany the diplomatic
process in the Korean Peninsula in this
respect I would like to commend and
appreciate the leadership of the
Republic of Korea president moon foreign
minister conch that have indeed put a
new hope not only in the Korean
Peninsula not only in Asia but in the
entire world and we are committed
together Europe and Asia to make these
negotiations a success and to accompany
them in the best possible manner
we also share the intention to uphold
the multilateral system with the United
Nations and its core all other
multilateral multilateral nuclear
non-proliferation agreements starting
from the jcpoa and another point we
discussed at length with a lot of
understanding and convergences is the
need to increase connectivity between
our two continents just last Monday a
few days ago the European Union foreign
ministers agreed on ways to strengthen
connectivity between Europe and Asia in
a sustainable comprehensive and
rules-based manner and I'm happy to see
that this approach is also shared by our
Asian partners so indeed we have decided
to use all the potential for bringing
Asia and Europe closer together not only
on the level of transport and
infrastructures but also on digital and
economic links as the Chancellor said
there is a clear commitment between us
to maintain and strengthen open free
trade to work for the reform of WTO
later this afternoon in a few hours
we'll design a new partnership free
trade and investment agreement with
Singapore only a few months after we
sign important agreements with Japan and
others are in the making so there is I
would say a new wave of
agreements trade agreements but also
partnership agreements the European
Union is promoting around the world and
in the asia-pacific region in particular
let me conclude by saying that the
summit was accompanied by many important
side events that reported to us the
results of their work civil society
business trade unions youth
parliamentarians from both our
continents and this is the real essence
of our partnership bringing people
together empowering people and I think
that this summit gives us the
possibility to use the full potential of
our joint strength thank you thank you
very much Minister Kang yes thank you
very much very honored to be part of
this press conference with the
Chancellor the High Representative and
my counterpart from the Philippines
first of all congratulations to
president tusk and high representative
mogherini for a very successful Assam
summit Asia and Europe are closer
together thanks to their efforts that
have resulted in a very successful
outcome and very fruitful conduct of
these meetings I think we all very much
walk away from the meetings assured of
the importance that we all place upon
the rule-based international order and
the centrality of multilateralism in
this whether it's trade or security
affairs or climate change and I think
our leaders walk away knowing that we
have partners not just in our regions
but across the world in Europe or Asia
that shared the same vision and they are
committed to working towards that vision
my president was very happy to share his
thoughts on what that means on a policy
level as global partners working on
global issues we've emphasized three
things that is the notion of inclusivity
not as a matter of economic policy but
as a philosophy that should undergird
all government decision-making basically
to ensure that we leave no one behind
which is also the philosophy that
undergird
the UN sustainable development goals
secondly we need to harness the
potential of the fourth Industrial
Revolution that benefits the people and
not fall into the same trap of
technology working out its way that
widens the gap rather than reduces them
we already see this happening the
digital gap is widening in many parts of
the world because we are not we are not
taking the issue very seriously but
having said all of that the potential of
the fourth Industrial Revolution and all
the technology that it it implies has
great potential and we all need to work
towards the the benefits and and to
mitigate the negative consequences of
that thirdly the connectivity between
Europe and ASEAN is something that we
are also very keenly involved and being
one of the most wired countries in the
world with IT sector that is
particularly enhanced we're ready to
contribute to enhancing and
strengthening the connectivity within
our regions but also across Europe and
Asia we of course had this opportunity
to brief their leaders on the
developments on the Korean Peninsula
and thank you frederica you've always
been a solid supporter behind all of our
diplomatic initiatives in this regard
but at the end we have a very different
situation on the Korean Peninsula from
where we were one year ago where we were
faced with continued North Korean
provocations and an even talk of a
potential for military clash to today
where we are solidly on the road to a
peaceful diplomatic resolution of North
Korea's nuclear missile challenge
coupled with a new phase in South North
Korean relations toward a dialogue and
reconciliation three South North Korean
summits one us North Korea's summit and
more in the making and so definitely we
are in a very change situation on the
Korean Peninsula and this would not have
happened without the support that we
have received from mood Frederika and
her team and certainly the members of
the the European Union as well so
and this was a wonderful opportunity for
us to brief and to assure the leaders
here that we are definitely on the right
track if we stay this course we get
denuclearization we get permanent peace
on the Korean Peninsula we will get
connectivity between Europe and Asia
even further strengthened as well
because once you have North Korea as
part of the normal economic activity on
the Korean Peninsula the peninsula will
be the link between South Asia to the
south and the Eurasian continent to the
north and of course that has to be a
great news for Asia Europe connectivity
as well
simply put Korean Peninsula non free of
nuclear weapons permanently a piece has
to be good for peace and prosperity in
that region but also the Northeast Asia
and the whole world indeed thank you
thank you thank you very much finally
foreign minister of the Philippines
thank you good afternoon we expressed
our deepest appreciation to our host the
European Union for the excellent
arrangements and the warm hospitality we
congratulate President Donald Tusk on
his feeding the aciem summit the
successful conclusion today the summit
brings us to a tighter partnership
between Asia and Europe to address
challenges global in scale and import
our talks covered a wide range of
concerns in politics economics and
culture and I added migration the Asian
experience with European histories the
other face of the European experience
with Asia
this summit no judgments were made about
that experience what there was instead
was a determined and cooperative effort
to discover the best possibilities of
the greatest mutual benefit by moving
forward Azam's value added was to show
how informal dialogue can move forward
even on the most difficult issues among
the issues I have no doubt developments
in the Korean Peninsula are the most
important today and in the future and a
C&E you meeting will take place later in
the day to talk about extending a
40-year dialogue into the next 40 years
two regions that account for some of the
best functioning economies and organized
societies of the present are involved
here and there's clearly something there
our value we intend to keep growing
thank you thank you very much we have
six minutes for the questions so we have
to be please please and their answers
please be very concise and say clearly
to whom you're posing your question to
I'll start with mm thank you very much
my M Rebecca with the Wall Street
Journal it's a question for everyone on
the podium who will take it on on the
conclusions you mentioned that the
leaders agreed to promote transparency a
level playing field and innovative
funding mechanisms now that everyone in
azzam is signed on to this principle do
you expect China to dial back some of
its practices with the belt and road
initiative including close tenders
non-transparent financing and what kind
of an impact do you see going forward
and access for other Asian partners in
big infrastructure projects in the
region as well as European companies who
want to get involved
we're living there currently what we're
seeing is that there have been
impressive and positive developments in
the economies of many Asian countries
which is a good thing for those
countries of course but also a major
opportunity for us as partners when it
comes to trade and it's important of
course for rules should be kept true
there is the expectation also on our
side that there will be a reform of the
WTO in areas where that is necessary and
in cases where we come up against
protectionism we reject it because free
trade has always got to be fair
equitable and rules based and that
applies in both directions ok Fritz over
there Peter flits Austrian television
ORF hi representatives to seen Italy's
budgetary plans and their possible
rejection by the European Commission the
potential for maybe worldwide contagion
for implications even beyond Europe in
as pertains to Asia maybe I appreciate
your effort to link the question to Asia
you might know that the basic rule of
this conference in press conferences is
that we stick to the issues we discuss
and definitely this was not an issue we
discussed during the summits Damon sorry
ok
then Robin on the other side from
Reuters question for the high rep high
rep but we saw that you had a bilateral
meetings from with the Cambodia and my
and my I wondered did you hear anything
today that would avoid both those
countries losing their special trade
status under everything but arms thank
you I had bilateral meetings with both
they are in different stages with
Cambodia we have taken the decision to
start the process of temporary
withdrawal of the ABA trade preferences
I've discussed with the Prime Minister
and this team what are our expectations
for what should happen for this not to
go on any particular the improvement of
the political Democratic climates I
would say in particular there is a lot
of concern in Europe but not only in
Europe about the dissolution in November
last year of the main opposition party
and in general terms the narrowed
Democratic space for political
opposition and civil society we
discussed this I cannot say that we find
solution we found solutions to any of
these issues but the European Union
approach is always that of engaging and
and having a dialogue especially when
problems arise we agreed that our teams
would work together starting in this
days and in the weeks to come to go
through a long list of issues that we
have raised together with our decision
of suspending the trade preferences and
I am always hopeful you know me that
positive change could come so the work
will continue with Myanmar it's a
different stage we are in the process of
sending in the coming weeks a mission in
Myanmar to discuss the issues that
worries us related to in particular the
situation in the rakion State for which
as you know the European Union has been
very active not only on the military
incites to support the Ringo's in
Bangladesh but also swear but also on
the political level trying to support
the full implementation of the
memorandum of understanding that was
signed bilateral between Myanmar and
Bangladesh and also the mo use there
were signs with the UNHCR and the UN and
UNDP I discussed this also with filippo
grandi
in the recent weeks I encourage the
authorities of Myanmar to fully
implement the memorandums they have
signed the agreements they've signed to
work in particular on accountability
because the results of the you are an
independent international fact-finding
mission are extremely serious and
worrying and they have to respond to
this kind of allegations and show
willingness to have accountability
transparency and to address the issues
that are raised there so we will
continue to accompany Myanmar in on its
path towards democracy it's a difficult
process we always knew it our support to
the democratization of the country will
not stop now but this doesn't mean that
we would close our eyes on violations
that the international community see as
worrying but on the EBA on the trade
preferences the decision has not been
taken yet but obviously there are rules
that we need to follow and you know that
our trade preferences have the respect
for human rights at their core so I hope
that there will be science on the
Myanmar authorities site that could
allow us to avoid that decision to be
taken in the future one final question
because unfortunately we don't need to
move on Thank You Deborah Haynes from
Sky News it's a question for foreign
minister Kang obviously South Korea has
a comprehensive free trade agreement
with the EU could you give us a sort of
realistic sense for people back in the
UK
once the UK leaves the European Union
will will the UK government be able to
achieve the same level of free trade
agreement with South Korea will it
actually achieve an even better terms
with South Korea or given that the UK is
a single country as opposed to a big
bloc like the EU well actually the terms
of the free trade agreement between
South Korea and the UK beyond uncertain
worst terms thank you well I won't go
into hypotheticals but we're very keen
to maintain the excellent relationship
that we've enjoyed with the UK
part of the European Union the UK is our
second largest trading partner in the
European Union under the FTA that's been
very beneficial to both sides and I
think I can safely say that on both
sides the UK and us were very keen to
maintain that level of collaboration
obviously this requires a lot of work a
lot of contingency planning if I may put
it that way but within our own
government but in collaboration with our
counterparts in the UK we are already
having serious discussions about this
and my president had an excellent
discussion with Prime Minister made
today thank you if I can if I can remind
us all though that as long as the UK is
part of the European Union they cannot
negotiate nor conclude any additional to
any separate trade agreements and this
includes the transition periods for us
to be all aware of what we're talking
about with this I have to conclude this
press conference but thank you very much
for coming and there is also ample
material available including the chairs
statement